ah my lips are so chapped hi guys my
name is Tamra chambers and this is
Tara's never seen also I kiss here so
last week I made a Twitter poll asking
what I should watch and Ferris Bueller's
Day Off one but coming in a close second
twas Groundhog Day which I've also never
seen so that's what I'm doing today I
don't know anything about this film
now the Bill Murray's in it you know
called Groundhog Day and I know the
groundhog day is February 2nd because my
birthday is February 7th and they're
close it's not important information I
just wanted everyone to know what I'm
still recovering from this crazy
sickness everyone is sick thank you for
the well wishes are you ready to watch
Groundhog Day yes I am camera I love
groundhog Judi does he loves groundhogs
yeah oh I've never seen we both enjoy
that a lot more than we thought we were
going to right right Ike right yes I
feel the same way you're so insightful
so Bill Murray is a weatherman and he's
a big old showman about it left the
showmanship in his weathering which is
the technical term he's fun to watch but
you can tell that you probably wouldn't
want to be his best friend or his lover
he's a little full of it so him and his
producer Rita and their camera guy are
going to this small town called
pennsatucky your pencil to gear
something with the pen in it they're
going to go see Phil who is the
groundhog that predicts whether it is
going to be six more weeks of winter or
not I love that both of their names are
filled because he hates it he does not
want to go to this small town this is
fourth year doing it and the silver
they're on the road they're in the car
going to see Phil the groundhog and the
producer is like I actually I think it's
really nice people like this he's like
people like blood sausage - it's
ridiculous which I also kind of agree
with blood sausage is ridiculous
I've only ever had like a small nibble
of it it freaks me out it's like it's
like blood right isn't it it's just like
curdled blood I don't know if it's
curdled or not not even really no crew
means I just don't think I like it
that's how I am about all food that I
don't like so I just haven't tried it I
moved to Chicago and I told someone that
I didn't like shrimp and they were like
what are you talking about you don't
like shrimp well I've never tried it but
it freaks me out
they're like the little bugs and then
they made me try one and then I loved it
I'm totally froze right now so maybe
that's the problem with blood sausage
this has gone way off topic let's get
back to the arrive to the small town and
he throws like a mini fit about where
he's going to stay and Rita the producer
is like we got you a really nice bed and
breakfast cool your jets I mean to be
fair he is the weather man for a local
news channel Beyonce who he's just kind
of treating everybody like crap like the
owner of the Ben breakfast brings up the
weather and he actually talked to her
about weather which is a pretty funny
joke she's like I was actually I was
trying to make small talk with you so he
runs into Ned who's an old high school
friends and she's the worst NetID so
annoying and then the whole silver
Groundhog Day things happens decides
this movie six more weeks of winter then
they get on the road to go back to
Pittsburgh because he does not like it
here and then they get stuck in a
blizzard that he said wasn't gonna
happen I feel like nobody sent a cool
job to have being a weatherman it's play
like the goof of the team for the
newscasters but also you're always wrong
because you can't accurately predict
whether 100 percent of the diamonds cool
job though question mark and maybe
secretly want to be a weatherman oh
whether human a weather kid he went the
a little weather cat I know I just kind
of want to sleep stop touching my face I
said so they get second puck to Tony or
wherever did it have no idea what this
is the city but then he wakes out the
next morning and of course the same day
today before the bed and breakfast owner
was like are you gonna check out date he
was like yes 100% chance of that
happening and for the second day he's
like 80% chance of that happening so
then it's like the third day
she finally tells Rita she doesn't
believe him he goes to doctor and that's
like hydrous and no one believes him so
he goes to a bowling alley next logical
step obviously then he comes to the
realization he can do anything and there
are no consequences for them because the
next day he'll just wake up so he goes
on to giant like ruining the spring of
ruining the city in this car he gets
pulled over he doesn't care and while I
think that's an interesting realization
to have that's not what I would do with
that information I don't think I would
just run into but maybe added like
desperation you're like going this is
the first thing I'll do I don't know how
many days I'll have to albumin tomorrow
do have none of things I don't know what
I do could you leave like could you book
a flight that morning and the whole
thing is he stuck in this bad town and
spent time that's the whole thing his
worst day ever but could you like I
don't know fly to a bunch of places and
then regain all your well for the next
day that would be cool that's what I
would want to do he's finding fun in it
like the fourth day he wakes up he sees
net any punches amount which is super
fun and he's starting to play around
with it he just eats like a giant feast
of like donuts and stuff the rain is
like what are you you don't care about
love handles and like well not as one
cares that love handles really different
then it ranged out into women he finds
Nancy who can ask sir information and
the next day uses that informations like
we went to high school together doors
remember me and uses that to have sex
with her so good for you I guess you
have how many days many whatever specify
how many days anyone else I'd like count
it cut it up you don't see them all I
wonder if it's like online somewhere how
many days this actually is that would be
interesting at this point I'm getting to
the part where I'm like I don't like
this character at all I hope he doesn't
get what he wants
it changes don't get mad at me yet but
accepted at this point I'm not a fan of
Phil he feels the kind of money and buys
a super fancy car goes out on a date
with another woman I think in this
scenario I think it's totally super okay
that you're gonna steal a ton of money
you know it's going to do the same day
tomorrow
I don't think just bad deal away man do
anything you want but don't murder I
can't think of really much else we don't
cause physical harm to people who she
doesn't at all so this is the part where
we start going after Rita he apparently
likes the most
I like this scenario where she gets to
go in all these different days figure
out what she likes have the perfect date
finally get the gold but it doesn't make
sense
in the long run even if you do start
dating even if the time does go back to
normal you don't actually like her you
liked this like version of her and she
liked you at all like she likes this
version of you and so dating isn't gonna
are you just gonna like trying to have
sex with her for like a job well done
and I also think it would be really
hilarious if at the end she got to see
the whole progression see how many dates
it took for you to finally snag it and
just the whole process I think that
would be hilarious that's what I thought
this movie was going in that direction
to where he was just trying to like have
sex with her and then it was gonna be
like we're together and it's done but
then quickly after my concerns were
addressed so he makes it to her room
finally one night and tells her that he
loved her and she's like what this is
all too calculated it's just for love
with to you and it's great she totally
calls him out on a then there's
just a slap montage because he continues
to try and she slaps him every day and
it's awesome cool I love it the address
I didn't think as we liked where this is
going and I freely did stop judging
things Tamara before you know they are
all right Tamara I'm sorry okay girl
don't be so hard on yourself then he
hits the depression points that is
inevitable in all of this he steals the
ground hook so Phil and Phil are on this
high-speed adventure don't Drive Angry
don't fret angry don't drive angry buddy
he drives his car off of a cliff and
dies and realizes that he can died
he'll come back and then there's a whole
like suicide spree that he goes on he
killed himself in a bunch of different
ways which is darker than I thought this
movie was going to go into and it was
interesting and made sense and I liked
it I liked it it was a good progression
of where it was going so he showed me a
to a point where he is
desperate enough to prove it Sherita as
if this is happening and she believes
him and they spent a really nice day
together and she's like I'm gonna stay
up with you and then in the morning
we'll see what happens and she falls
asleep and he does this whole like
declaration of love to her doesn't pull
any moves on her even though they she
doesn't think that and it was my I was
surprised I kept being surprised during
this movie about how much I liked it I
didn't think I was going to I don't know
why cuz I did it I didn't think I would
like it and kept surprising me so he
decides to be kind and selfless he's
reading a lot he's learning piano that's
what I would do I would just learn a
bunch of learn a new instrument
learn a new language to read my whole
list of books that I want to read or a
time to be kind of smarter and more
learning individual because I rent a lot
of cats I mean I would rent a lot of cat
and you know so out of it I would adopt
a lot of cat every day
it kills Ned with kindness and that is
like I - I'm gonna go now save this kid
for a tree saves this guy from with a
Heimlich maneuver from choking these
women they have a flat tire and he helps
them you like play piano for this whole
citywide party and Rita shows up and
sees it and that is like the moment when
you're like ah now they're gonna fall in
love but in the right way it's a cute
movie way going back to real life
after knowing every single thing that
happens being able to really help it
would just be such a trip she's gonna
seem like such a doofus acceptances and
there's this part after they're on this
date because she did on him where he
makes an ice sculpture of her face and
she sees it and it's beautiful she's
like that's incredible how did you do it
and he goes I know your face so well I
could have done it with my eyes closed
what Oh lime I was like oh okay well
John is our wonder how we do that and he
told her that she loves her and actually
is really wonderful and he's like I'm
just happy whatever happens tomorrow I
know it's gonna be okay but just right
now I'm half
and is the first time I think the heat
it was just really nice it was so nice
and she was like I'm going to be too
this spell has to be broken whatever is
happening here has to be broken and then
they wake up the next morning and he's
like this is different she's like good
news I guess anything anything different
is good and they start kissing and she's
like where was this last night you
didn't do anything last night and he's
like well I'm sorry I was tired it was
the end of a very long day and that was
a great line I really didn't think oh
girl like him and I love redeemed
characters this was such a cheesy like
early 90s weird wacky thing happening
adventure film and I super loved it I
loved it actually was great story was
cute I want to know how many days it was
total it surprised me in a wonderful way
I put the poll up on Twitter Groundhog
Day was the one that got the most
responses like written though people
were like I love Groundhog Day really I
just thought maybe it was like a
sentimental nostalgic thing and and I
did I thought of such a fun movie but
check out my own personal channel Tamra
Lynne chambers at youtube-dot-com I post
there every Friday so a new video went
up yesterday if you want to promote
anything just too much to promote so he
just is a little overwhelmed hopefully
next week I won't be sick thanks for all
the well wishes guys thanks for watching
and I'll see you soon bye
[Music]